ورفض مناسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي
تاكيد او نفي بدء القوات الاوكرانيه شن
هجومي المضاد على روسيا واشار كيربي الى
ان بلاده عملت على توفير كل ما تحتاجه
للانتصار في الحرب وان واشنطن لا تدعم شن
هجمات داخل روسيا
لن اتحدث نيابه عن الجيش الاوكراني واعتقد
انه قال في وقت سابق انه يشن بعض العمليات
الهجوميه لكنني لن اتجاوز ذلك ما يمكنني
التحدث عنه هو مدى العمل المضني الذي قمنا
به لاعداد وتدريب القوات الاوكرانيه حتى
تكون مستعده لذا سواء بدا الهجوم المضاد
الان او سيبدا قريبا فان الرئيس واثق
باننا فعلنا كل ما في وسعنا خلال الاشهر
السته او الثمانيه الماضيه للتاكد من ان
لدى القوات الاوكرانيه جميع المعدات
والقدرات حتى تنجح